[Music]
tonight former president Donald Trump is
scheduled to deliver the closing speech
at the annual conservative political
action conference called CPAC which is
being held in Maryland not far from
Washington D.C the annual Gathering is a
launching point for Republican leaders
while Trump has already announced his
third bid for the White House this
year's conference is being seen as a
Crossroads for the Republican Party CBS
News Chief election and campaign
correspondent Robert Costa has more
thank you very much and it's great to be
back where it all started with the great
Patriots of CPAC thank you very much a
year ago former president Donald Trump
took the stage at CPAC the annual
conservative political action conference
and teased another presidential run we
did it twice and we'll do it again we're
going to be doing it again now a year
later he will return to the CPAC stage
on Saturday night this time as an
official presidential Contender I am
tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States but
tonight's closing speech won't be a
typical check the box moment for Trump
with his party's base we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob here in
Florida this is where woke goes to die
just days after Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis launched a book tour where he
has touted his record in Florida many
Republican voters and elected off
officials are increasingly keeping their
options open as the 2024 presidential
race begins to develop let's say there
it is Trump at 71 Rhonda sanctimonia
said 10 percent Trump has taken shots at
DeSantis in recent months and tonight's
speech could be revealing in what he
says or perhaps doesn't say about
DeSantis who is widely seen by party
strategists and donors as a top rival
wouldn't you like to know
DeSantis has so far been Coy about
whether he will run but others haven't
been including the former U.S ambassador
to the United Nations Nikki Haley who
declared her bid last month I don't put
up with bullies
back
it hurts them more
than more wearing heels kealia former
South Carolina governor spoke at CPAC on
Friday afternoon as she continues to try
to carve out her own space in the
Republican Party America is not past our
Prime it's just that our politicians are
past theirs while Haley and Trump are on
the CPAC agenda others are staying away
from the conference including DeSantis
and former vice president Mike Pence
another possible presidential Contender
the move by some prominent Republicans
to stay away from CPAC comes as the
conference's leadership faces legal
issues questions over its relevance plus
scrutiny of the confab's friendly ties
with Trump and with far-right Hungarian
prime minister Victor Orban and it has
been sharply criticized by democrats but
many Trump align Republicans keep
showing up rallying conservative voters
on Thursday and on Friday and despite
the appearances by his competitors CPAC
remains a political homecoming of sorts
for Trump where amid ongoing
investigations of his conduct and of the
capital attack and of his handling of
classified materials he'll get cheers
and many Republicans say running against
him and beating him will be tough in the
months ahead it's a tricky balancing act
as I learned in my campaign it's not an
easy thing to fall off or to do when
you're learning for president's heart
running against Donald Trump is really
former president Trump's stop at CPAC
comes as he and a number of Republicans
are ramping up their political travel
both Trump and Governor DeSantis are
scheduled to visit Iowa home to the
presidential caucuses later this month
and so will former Ambassador Haley
among others as this early pre-primary
race for dollars and for Buzz carries on
for CBS Saturday morning Robert Costa
Washington